let's see um let's burn dialectics and
see if we can get some um content going
Vanguard welcome
hi David oh my God I've seen your show
you pretty big creative what's happening
it's it's a pleasure having you join me
it's a pleasure being here my dad
actually loves you a lot so just a bit
about me I'm actually a communist my
father's a big liberal though so he
watches your show a lot I can't wait to
do so we'll say hi to your dad for me
thank you how you doing how's that how
you feeling about the current political
climate what's your biggest word
completely it's completely toxic and
disgusting and the right has become so
weaponized that it's really kind of
putting the country in a humiliating
position yeah so from my perspective
um I think we're condescending into some
Christian fascism right we have see the
attack on voting rights we see an
increase in
anti-lgbtq anti-immigrant rhetoric and
all these things and not to mentioned
the economic system I know you have your
feelings about capitalism I have mine
but I think we can both agree that
there's a lot of contradictions coming
to the floor right now growing
inequality stagnating wages labor shares
going down you know the portion of
income that's going to the workers now I
ask you um how can we what do you think
is some of the solutions economically to
some of these problems like how can we
stop fascism in your eyes
well there's two different things
there's the economic concerns and then
when you talk to me about fascism I
think more about the authoritarianism on
the right the anti-media rhetoric on the
right these are two different categories
they do overlap for sure but the
economic stuff and the fascist stuff
really are two different things
yeah okay yeah how about economics yeah
with economics I mean there there's a
large variety of things that have to be
done one
we need more tax brackets as we go up
with the very rich paying more taxes
than they do now at the at the top you
know successively higher tax brackets
um I think we need to reduce the amount
that we're spending on defense and
redirect those funds to bettering both
education and providing Health Care to
folks paid paternity and maternity leave
you know it's kind of like a standard
social democracy program right I would
like to see at minimum free Community
College uh if not more you know it's
quite a long list I'd like to see more
democratization of the workplace I'd
like to say yeah boards for companies
larger than a certain number of
employees right okay yeah that's that's
really the Crux because
um we see it was supposed to Marcus is
obviously better uh human development
index than what we see here and
obviously I support those social
democracies um and in comparison to uh
more liberal democracies were here
um as we are here but um my question
with um
the worker worker ownership like how do
you feel about full worker ownership do
you have thoughts on that
I think it's absolutely fine if that is
what a company wants to do but I'm
against the government coming in from
above and saying every company must be
evenly owned by their employees that I'm
against that strikes me as authoritarian
but I think it's great for companies to
choose to organize that way okay okay
you say authoritarian seems to me
authoritarian to you as some invalid use
of the state is that how you would say
authoritarian so it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be this it doesn't
have to be the state but for me I tend
to be a SP not a not a Libertarian like
the libertarian party yeah I just mean
like a small L libertarian when I when
you give me options between
authoritarianism and libertarianism
unless there's some real particular
reason to say we need more involvement
like with health care I would say no we
need to establish certain things we
don't care I lean to the libertarian
side right okay so let me ask let me get
and if you have you have to go in a
little bit let me know let me get really
now into the heat of where we disagree
because all that most stuff we agree on
now please to me as a comments I'm a
Marxist right so not particularly
Marxist lenis I don't think one party
should be directing the state in that
specific way but Emma Marxist is not
afraid to use the state and to me this
state's Prime job especially on under
capitalism is to ensure uh Surplus value
extraction meaning that there's a
capitalist class that extracts Surplus
that the workers don't have rights over
controlling uh and we see this basically
play out right we all go to work and we
produce that Surplus but we don't get to
touch those profit rates right we we
it's considered the owner's private
property and even after these businesses
establish themselves years and years
even after they have different CEOs it's
often still it's always still structured
like that and capitalism to me that's
time theft I mean Mark's laid it out on
Capital not time I'm sorry it's a theft
of your service labor time staffed of
your Surplus labor meaning that like I I
help produce Surplus but I don't get to
choose what to do with that to me that's
inherently authoritarian as well hold on
a second can I ask you about that yeah
yeah yeah yeah
just as a thought experiment and I'm not
saying I'm a Social Democrat so I'm in
between these ideas yeah just to propose
something to you you've got the employee
whose Surplus value is being extracted
and they only get a portion of it as
their wage and then the difference the
capitalist keeps right so Standard
Market stuff good so if the business
fails
the employee can very easily go and get
another job whereas the capitalist loses
their investment they potentially go
under and are financially bankrupt so do
you we can talk about the specifics but
do you concede that we have very
different circumstances in terms of what
the worker has at risk and what the
owner has at risk and the scenario you
outlined is that fair uh in your as you
explained it yes I'd have to concede
that but I think that we have to
understand the broader context in which
this is happening for instance as we
know in all beginning Capital societies
though the population was forcibly
removed from the means of production
right the Native Americans were
genocided the enclosure action Britain
the birthplace of capitalism right these
weren't voluntary actions as John Locke
liked to paint right like there were
markets before capitalism you know but
the act of producing uh establishing
private property that was a violent act
to begin with so there was really in
reality it was uh the state came in and
it backed the capitalists from day one
from day one day we're kind of getting
off off track so now we're talking about
something totally different here okay
I I mean listen I I understand your
perspective I disagree with it but since
we're kind of like going fractally
branching here let me get on to more
people but I think it's great that
you're doing this stuff on Tick Tock
okay I appreciate David I'd love if you
want to follow me we can stay in touch
if not you have a good day I'm always
want to talk thank you for your time
David I'll see you later beautiful all
right thank you very much there's a
Vanguard dialectics with some
extraordinarily powerful declarations
and I'm really glad that he was able to
make them let's see who else wants to
join why don't we go to it's Dede it's
Dede is going to be joining us here uh
we are celebrating 200 000 Tick Tock
followers and the next person joining me
is Dede welcome Hi how are you I'm doing
well how are you I'm fine
um there wasn't much that I really
wanted to say but like I started
watching your content maybe like a year
or so ago this is while I was like the
libertarian I'm not communist right now
I know you're not but like yeah that's
why you went from being a Libertarian
you were a free Market libertarian and
now you became a communist
oh okay
yeah then I just became radicalized and
I first actually want to watch your
content I thought you were a socialist
but then I saw your video um you did a
video on um something about socialism
and then um I like looked up like are
you a socialist tonight you said no you
don't fully agree with socialism and
like I don't think you really like dive
out into it and I have mutuals with um
with the person that's that was just on
the live and like I just got here so did
you like explain that already or or
would you be willing to like did I
explain why I'm not a socialist
oh I mean my general my general view is
I don't have any problem
with markets directing resources and
generating profit in many areas so for
example you know basketball sneakers or
mobile phones or automobiles
laptops
gardening equipment I think it's
basically fine to say let's let markets
and supply and demand dictate resources
and allow profits however
because I'm a Social Democrat I want to
make sure that we're taking some of
those profits
sing the very wealthy and saying we're
going to use that money to ensure nobody
in society Falls below a certain
standard of living everybody should have
housing access to education access to
health care and food we're a really rich
country there's no reason that that
shouldn't be the case and certain
markets should rather certain industries
should not be in the market and subject
to supply and demand so with health care
with education Etc that's my view I
think for the government to come in and
say every industry every business must
have ownership and means of production
socialized is authoritarian I think if
businesses choose to organize that way
beautiful do it but I'm against the
government mandating that that be
required
so is this like towards like a Ubi sort
of like stance or is it like baseball
well Ubi is a policy Ubi is a policy and
I think UBI has pros and cons sometimes
Ubi is proposed to replace all social
welfare programs and I don't know that
I'm super for that that really depends
on the details but Ubi would be a policy
that I'm then certainly open to
considering yeah okay
okay I I yeah I mean you know I don't
like I like that to give private
property so yeah that's not my stance
but do you think there should be no
private property yeah I don't think that
anything should be privately owned I
believe what about like your mobile what
about like I know that there's I know
that some Communists get mad when when
people like me go this way but should
you be allowed to like own your car yeah
absolutely
um probably okay I saw your video like
you know this already come on
remember like you differentiated already
yeah so tell me okay yeah personal
property private property like all are
different proper property refers to like
things you only use to like make okay
fair fair so you I was just seeing if
you made that distinction oh I do I
forgot my question but like I remember
now so like do you support like
nationalizing certain industries I know
you you already explained with like
healthcare education yeah I just said
that yeah but like level like gas or
um like just something like that like
how about that with oh gas or Airline do
you support like um nationalizing those
Industries
I think Airlines is a tough case which
I've studied quite a bit and there are
countries where that's gone well and
countries where it's been a disaster
with gasoline I just think we need to
get off a gasoline period and and that I
mean I it's hard for me to even take
seriously should we nationalize gasoline
because we should just be getting off of
gasoline yeah okay I agree with that
okay and all right well Dede it's been I
really appreciate you joining me today
one more thing one more thing so you did
this um interview with Jesse Lee
um something you know who this is
Peterson yes yes him oh my God that
interview was literally hilarious and I
love how you acted a week I'm in my bed
right now so I work on Max but that
video oh sorry I what I was trying to do
was was turn up your mic oh God now we
can see you oh my god did I turn on your
video yes
do I have the control to turn people's
video on forces actually didn't like
kick me if you if I didn't press oh my
God no no I'm sorry no no no that was a
great listen Dede I you've said it all
I'm Gonna Let You Go okay it's been a
pleasure all right all right thank you
there's DD
folks everything everything going wrong
here during this uh during this live
stream